kiev où un cessez-le-feu donc de 36
heures a été annoncé il entrera en
vigueur ce soir et jusqu'à jeudi matin
marina bertsch bonjour bonjour commencer
par se concentrer ensemble sur l'état
d'avancée des troupes russes au niveau
de la capitale ukrainienne où est ce
qu'on en est exactement alors très
concrètement vous lisiez les frappes
s'intensifient
alors évidemment il y un cessez-le-feu
donc pour l'instant ces frappes elles
vont être mises en pause 36 heures ce
soir 20h jusqu'à sept heures jeudi matin
et on a des précisions les habitants ne
seront autorisés à sortir que pour se
rendre dans des abris anti bombe bien
entendu pour leur protection ça c'est
des images de ce qui s'est passé ce
matin dans un quartier résidentiel
immeuble de 15 étages dans le centre de
quilles ajout propose pour mieux
comprendre où ça se situe exactement de
regarder une carte des quartiers de kiev
intra muros voilà exactement où ça s'est
passé le quarté le quartier de soho
viatteau chine on a eu aussi d'autres
frappes un peu plus haut à pau deal et à
dernier depuis hier au dessus là où
c'est en jaune sur notre carte c'était
ici à aubes olonne donc très clairement
ça se resserre sur la capitale on a même
des photos du métro de kiev là le métro
qui a été regardé cette station de métro
du coeur de kiev 1 qui a été endommagé
par ce qui s'est passé ce matin donc oui
très clairement l'offensive se rapproche
du centre de kiev même si il faut le
rappeler se sont principalement quand ça
arrive des tirs d'artillerie parce que
l'armée russe ne maîtrise pas encore le
ciel de kiev la défense anti-aérienne
fonctionne bien je vous regarde proposé
de regarder ce qui se passe non pas dans
le centre de kiev mais maintenant un
tout petit peu plus largement on va
dézoomer ensemble les combats se
poursuivent à l'ouest dans cette région
qu'on connaît bien maintenant au sto
mail butch haïr pin les forces russes
ont mené plusieurs attaques à mes
limites et hier et puis elles ont tenté
de jeter un pont sans succès sur la
rivière ir qui ici dans l'est à brovary
pas de nouvelle offensive russe ces
dernières 24 heures ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que cette progression
rue c'est bien elle est empêché par la
résistance de poche ukrainienne ailleurs
ça se passe notamment ici à tchernihiv
et puis donc dans cette périphérie là et
donc les forces russes sont en train de
se réorganiser de se ravitailler et ils
ont bien du mal à maîtriser cette ligne
de communication ici pourra sécuriser
leurs lignes d'approvisionnement donc
pour l'instant du côté russe on est
plutôt en pause opérationnelle
les nids de frontier qui bouge peu en
finalement en ce moment un an peut-être
des derniers développements ailleurs oui
ça bouge peu la quasi-totalité de des
offensives militaires russes sont au
point mort sauf peut-être dans le sud en
fête les forces russes ont très peu
progressé ces derniers jours et on ne
doit pas s'attendre à des percées
majeures cette semaine je vous propose
de regarder ensemble la carte générale
de l'ukraine là encore un pour bien
comprendre ce qui se passe sur le
terrain regardez ici à kharkhiv bien les
forces l'ukrainienne ont repoussé les
forces russes au sud-est de kharkiv situ
par ici la verrerie zoom mais les
bombardements continuent on a ce nouveau
bilan ce matin sept personnes qui ont
été retrouvées mortes sous les décombres
d'un bâtiment qu'elle 65 bombardements
en seulement 24 heures / car qu'ils sont
totalement pilonner la stratégie des
russes ici c'est quoi et bien ces deux
contourner karkhiv par le sudes et
d'avancer vers ni pro ici et apporter
ici d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un hasard si
les forces russes ont bombardé ce matin
même le principal aéroport civil ici
destruction massive selon le gouvernant
je propose aussi de regarder le front
sud vers donetsk ici ou très clairement
les troupes russes avancent mais elle
avance lentement mais sûrement et le but
ici c'est aussi de rejoindre la porte
j'ai tout simplement pour couper
marioupol qui je vous le rappelle reste
sous attaque non-stop des bombardements
lourds qui sont toujours
en cours et puis un dernier point
elisabeth sur le sud avec personne selon
les dernières informations les forces
russes disent avoir pris le contrôle
total de la région de kherson mais
visiblement les ukrainiens qui sont sur
place résiste au contrôle russe on a
notamment vu des manifestations anti
russe à kherson ces derniers jours voilà
merci beaucoup marine